we're going to start with number nine
Max data versioning with 10 operations
all right Max give it up for Max
everyone all right I will give you a go
there's a microphone right here in my
other
hand that see if we've got it up and
going all right one second I will let
you know um when I say everybody give it
up for Max I'll be back here with the l
you're up on Deck I mean I can also
scream but yeah all right oh we've got a
mic issue is it on everybody mic check I
just have to turn it on that was easy
all right everybody give it up for
[Applause]
Max hi uh so I'm Max I flew all the way
here from Munich and Germany and yeah so
I haven't prepared any fancy slides I
recycled that one because that was very
much much a gut decision I my gut is
regretting right now but I hope you
learn something so I want to talk about
data versioning which is important when
you work with production use cases of uh
machine learning models because you have
in like more complex uh yeah setups
continuously uh data is coming in and uh
first of all because you want to have or
be a rigorous data scientist you might
want to roll back your models uh and
maybe something unexpected happens and
you want to investigate why did that
happen why is the model now suddenly
performing a lot better or a lot worse
um and it's a lot easier when you can
look into your data and reproduce the
exact data that you use back then to uh
train your model and then if you're as
fortunate as I am to live in Europe and
have the AI act coming up it's also
required by law that you have to uh
version your data so if you're working
on use cases that are deployed in Europe
you might also want to look into Data
versioning um so this is just how does
data diverge in the different or can
data diverge in organizations you can
have splits and then at some point uh
have questions about your data and when
you have a data versioning system it's
easy to roll uh back and figure out what
went wrong or right
um then this I'm in no way affiliated
with lfs but for a reason that I'm going
to tell on later I I like them a lot is
one they they are basically One open
source tool that you can use uh to uh
for data versioning and it's basically a
g-like uh structure so you have
different branches uh you commit your
data files onto them um you can merge
branches uh you can have like Def and
pro setups um so nothing new here if
you're familiar with Git um but so how
you use them or the the way you're using
them is sometimes a bit clunky you can
see on their landing page on the right
that if you want to create a branch uh
that's these five five lines of code and
now we come to the Place why I'm excited
to talk about that because I'm uh or my
company is developing or has developed a
small neat little open source project
called lakeef spec um which is what I'm
showing you here so it's basically a
wrap around uh the lakeef system that
makes it easier to uh read and write to
the different branches of your Lake
system so you have once you set up a
small little config file um and then you
can either here like you see here in
this uh cell number five uh put a file
to the system um or if you look down
which is even uh easier then with the
lfs spec package installed which is what
we developed uh it can recognize lfs as
a file specification so with your pandas
read or write operations or everything
that has uh FS spec under the hood you
can basically in your own workflow as
you have use uh data versioning with
Lake ofs um under the hood and we have
neat little features like uh post
execution Hooks and so on that can
execute custom hooks whenever you read
or write uh file so um yeah that's what
I wanted to tell you about I think I'm
is faster than I thought minute and a
half a oh Jesus um then we can look how
how that then looks in NS basically you
have here A A UI where you can see yeah
the different files that are on there um
I have no uncommitted changes but you
also have a a committed
and so on um I didn't go over the full
demo because that would take a lot more
than 5 minutes but I'll stick around
after the talk if you want to know more
about data versioning or about lfs spec
um yeah lfs lfs spec just type that into
Google and I hope you learned something
the two things I want you to take away
version your data that's good scientific
practice and helps you to comply and L
spec is a neat little open source tool
um that can help you with that by the
way uh the company I'm like we have a
comp company but I work for its
nonprofit arm so there's no caveats
except you didn't like the tool when you
use it
thanks for
ma all right give it up for ma taking
five minutes look easy just go ahead and
leave that here we've got our next
speaker we've got cir debug your ner
data with Recon so go ahead there's the
plug there there's a
mic wow I love this audience you guys
are getting warmed
up hello hello oh sorry what in one
second we'll do one quick let me type in
the next random number or did nine
number eight so so right do that corly
so all right awesome you're up on Deck
just is a friendly reminder all right
take it away five minutes starts now all
right hey everyone I'm Kabir I work at
explosion we have a a booth down on the
fifth floor if you want to stop by and
talk more about any of this stuff um but
I'm going to talk about a little bit of
a specialized topic uh named entity
recognition is this task in natural
language processing for information
extraction I have an example up uh here
on the screen using our uh my company's
explosions Library Spacey hopefully a
few of you have used it before um
basically you're just trying to identify
um you know not entities in a sentence
so here we have an English sentence
we're looking at labels like person and
organization and date um pretty
self-explanatory when you actually see
an example um but the issue here is that
there's a lot of data sets that have
been published uh that are pretty trash
um so there's a lot of issues in them
and uh especially if you're trying to
build your own data set for named ed
edty recognition to do your own uh
modeling this uh data quality issue
becomes a real um becomes a real big
issue um so I I built this library and
this the topic of today it's called
Recon um the goal behind Recon is to
help you get quick stats about your data
um specifically focused on ner and uh
find the disparities in the annotations
so let's say you have a few different
annotators working on a problem they
might have a different ideas of what a
label should be for a particular entity
um it helps you find the hardest
examples for a model to predict um there
a lot of just basically a full toolbox
to help you debug and correct your data
ultimately with the goal of having a
high quality NE data set uh so I'm going
to take you through a quick example uh
just with the conell 2003 data set so
this is like one of the most popular
well-published data sets um and it's
also riddled with mistakes um so we're
just going to take a quick tour uh this
is a bit short notice for me so it's not
a full-fledged uh example but hopefully
some of this stuff is useful um so we'll
start by just loading the uh data set
from uh hugging base's data set Library
um
and there's a little converter in Recon
to get it in the Recon data set format
uh none of this stuff is that
interesting so far um one of the biggest
issues is uh just like knowing your
distribution of your labels so it's in a
named eny recognition model it's
important to have uh balanced labels or
somewhat balanced labels at least um so
this is kind of a a nice just like easy
stats finding Mission um the first
interesting piece though is this entity
coverage um so you can start to get an
idea of uh if your data set is like
really skewed towards something like
news um you'll get you know like what's
the latest drama with uh you know the US
president or whatever and you'll get a
lot of instances of examples where
that's been annotated um in this case we
have a lot of locations annotated
because these are news articles um and
you can see some of the like least
annotated examples are just like
individual people's names Um this can
give you an idea of what you need to
focus on so if you what kinds of a raw
data to put into your pipeline so your
annotators can sort of balance out this
data set a little
more um we also have label disparities
so the idea here is which spans of texts
are getting labeled sometimes as one
label sometimes as another these uh
happen um so you're here you're looking
for the ones that are a little bit lower
numbered because usually those are
actually mes um that an aner made so
these higher numbered ones there's
actually some ambiguity but uh these
lower numbered ones are there's actually
often somebody just selected the wrong
label um I think I'm running it a little
short on time so I'm going to skip a
little bit ahead one of the most useful
workflows is just uh if you have a
trained model you can
uh you can use that model uh to run
predictions on the dev set and then uh
you can calculate what the hardest
examples are for the model to actually
work with just based off of like an
individual F1 score for each
example uh and then those are sorted by
Recon and you come up with some examples
where you actually have some real data
quality issues so uh just in our
training set we actually have this
inconsistency with this first example um
where The annotation the annotators
Follow The annotation guidelines here so
our prediction is this second line This
English County Championship cricket
matches on Thursday this is actually
cor thanks
everybody here's oh Peter's born ready
everybody let's give it up for Peter um
Peter your time Stars the mic works okay
okay so my now my my name is p and I
would like to show you the auto mail
package that I'm working on and it's is
a python package and so you can just
drop the the tabular data into it and
you will have a lot of uh machine
learning pipelines ready and so you you
will have the leaderboard with with your
model and you know uh I always thought
that the most important thing when you
were doing uh MML package for other
others it is the you know the the
performance but it looks like not only
performance is important in autl tool
but also the documentation and we have
such feature that uh automatically
creates documentation for each model so
I I will show you quick demo so here you
have the the outl object and the the the
the fit function that that is training
machine learning uh pipelines and I I
train the alml on
U uh on Titanic data
and I I I will show you the uh the
report that is generated by our autl so
you have the leaderboard with different
models you have the the performance
metric for every model and a lot of
plots for example the the performance
and the iteration of the
altl uh a feature importance heat mop so
you have the feature importance for
every model and it is put uh put it uh
in one plot the the correlation between
models and you can click for any model
and check the details for example hyper
parameters validation metrics and a lot
of different a lot of plots so
and you
can so the the automile package is open
source and you can check it on on GitHub
and if you are able to manually create
the the better model than our autl I I
will buy you a
beer woo and if I still have a time I
will show you one more tool that that I
created so it is called plot AI it is uh
connecting M lip with uh CH GPT so you
can uh just write uh in in Python what
what kind what what chart you would like
to have I will start so for example here
a plot that make uh bar plot of income
and and you have a prompt sent to the
Chart GPT and in the response you have
the python code and in the background we
execute the python code and you have the
the chart ready so you don't have to
remember all all M clip uh syntax and
you know it can even work with
complicated uh
plots and here is the link for for the
plot that's all thank
you all right get my Tim going all right
you have five minutes I'll give you
light at one time starts now all right
thank you everyone uh my name is Saul
and I'm going to present on EGS in
Python with a library called egog This
is built off of a Russ library that I
didn't write but I wrote The Python
bindings so what is what are EGS and
what is this Library so the goal is to
have a faithful binding to the r Library
a pythonic interface and to have it be a
base for other data science libraries to
build upon when they're building
expression systems or rewrite systems so
this this library is really aimed at
other data science libraries to use
internally so what is an
egph um EGS are like a data structure
that comes out of the automated theorem
proving kind of community and the
equality saturation community so
basically from academic computer science
and they can be used to write rewrite
systems which can be used to write
compilers so another way to think about
them as basically you define some types
you def find some expression and then
you write rewrite rules they could be
kind of like mathematical rewrite rules
to convert between those expressions and
then extract out like a lowest cost
expression and that would give you your
like compiled form so we'll go into an
example because this is quite
abstract so we'll start by making a sort
of a numpy alike array right an ND array
very simple here just you can add or
multiply and you can uh create an A
Range so you notice that when I Define
this I don't actually write bodies for
any of these functions all I'm doing is
writing their signatures their type
signatures and then I can write a
rewrite rule for example I can say X
Plus X I can rewrite that the x * 2
right those are like equivalent and
maybe x * 2 is faster for some
reason so one thing to notice again I'm
writing this with just python of
functions I don't have to write any like
you know ad class like you would if you
writing like maybe some other kind of
system and I can use and this all works
with my pi and type
annotations so now I can make a function
or an expression a range of 10 + 10 and
if I add it to my eaph it looks like
this so I'm adding a range of 10 to
itself so those are the two arrows here
the two arguments to add are is the same
expression and then if I run my rewrite
rule I can see that this is now
equivalent to the multiplication of a
range with two so this um this this here
is the equivalence class so it shows
that these two expressions are actually
equal to each other um you could
substitute one for the other and you get
the same result and so then we can
extract out our lowest cost expression
for our our input and say okay that's a
range of 10 * 2 so this is a very tiny
example um but I hope this gives you a
flavor of what's working under the hood
and now I'm going to go with a slightly
larger
example so let's say I'm using scikit
learn and I'm doing some kind of
classification um and let's say I wanted
to go faster so I might want to try to
use Numba right but let's say num Numba
actually doesn't support pit learn so I
can't you know wrap a jet decorator on
this it's not going to work so what can
I do what I can do is I can use um the
egg log array API implementation and
pass that into my function and basically
execute this um pit learn function on an
abstract array so I make some
assumptions about the shape and D type
of my input but I don't know anything
about the
data skip that and then what I get out
at the end is this huge long abstract
expression which which is what pyit
learn is actually doing under the hood
when it's doing this function so you're
basically extracting out the information
that pyit learn is performing and then
we can actually compile this back to
python code so you see now we just have
a bunch of numpy operations we see we
have the SVD which takes most of the
time here but there's a bunch of other
stuff that's going on and so this is a
form that actually NBA can um optimize
right Numba can hand handle standard
numine this is also a graph
representation which is is very small
and really ineligible but you can get a
sense of like this is this is the form
that umit learn is generating so then we
can you know call number on it we can do
a little Benchmark and we can see oh
well when I was doing my Benchmark
earlier was faster and now it's slower
so there you go for a live demo but uh
it's at least equivalent functionality
so the conclusions here are not that you
should use this instead of some other
array Optimizer but that it's flexible
enough to build systems like this I can
inform to the numpy array spec you could
pass them in and they work just like the
numpy array but you can Implement
rewrites and add your own optimization
so hopefully it's a way for different
array libraries or other data science
libraries in the python ecosystem to
work better together because they can
compose more easily one Library could
just write the ND interface and another
Library could write rewrites on it so
there could be um a greater basically uh
collaboration between libraries so thank
you so
much
[Applause]
okay so this is a regular pandas data
frame and we're going to look at this
and I'm going to press the right
button so some columns and numbers
there's something really important about
this when you look at when you sort it
by value by column A 211,000 isn't
obviously the largest value there that's
a problem when you analyze data the
first step is looking at the data and we
can't trust the tools that we use by
default and yes there is a way to fix
that in pandis but let me show you
Buckaroo and what that same data frame
looks like in
Buckaroo this is buckaroo and then we
can just sort the column there and
everything lines
up so we'll still I'll show a more
complex example when you import buckaroo
it replaces the default pandas display
method uh for data frames so here is a
data frame with 3 ,000 rows of city bike
data it has not displayed 300,000 rows
it's displayed 10,000 because the down
samples otherwise performance would be a
problem we can still sort we can look at
summary
stats
and there are some histograms here we'll
get more into those and you can also
scroll left and
right I'm doing this wrong hand this
will be easier so here are some common
histograms you can see a normal
distribution exponential and increasing
when I look at data I want to know
what's going on with it really quickly
here is a column with only a single
value here's a column with three
categories and decreasing value and this
is what all unique values look like you
have a separate bar for
that here's some more about categorical
historys na gets its own type of bar um
in longtail values you have two or more
off
so this works for polers
also and it works in Google
collab and vs
code I got tired of cleaning data frames
the same way over and over again so I'm
going to show you the same data frame
with auto cleaning turned
off and here's birth year obviously you
want a number
there here's what the data cleaning
looks
like okay so you see that we stripped
out all those SL ends this is done
puristic
and we have all these operations there's
also a low code UI built in where
operations like this or or added this is
not the best explanation there's also
python generated code for
this all of this is extendable so you
can add your own summary stats there's a
dag built in so you can have a summary
stat in terms of another here we will
add uh variance in terms of
mean and we just say this depends on
mean
and um if return turns variance and then
we set the list
display you do the same things over and
over again you shouldn't type this in
over and over again your tool should
help you do this uh there's more to this
you can add your own commands to the low
code UI but for now the takeaway is try
Buckaroo today pip install Buckaroo
import Buckaroo and check it out on
GitHub Buckaroo dodev uh redirects to
the GitHub page thank
you
holy C you guys are all fast today how's
everybody doing today good W woo that
didn't sound like we're actually going
well let's let's try again how's
everybody doing
today awesome awesome uh I'm Jeff hail
with prefect I'm going to talk to you a
little bit about workflow application
Frameworks what does that mean why are
we talking about it how do we do it
that's the thing we're going to talk
about so um I'm going to suggest that
you probably have workflows or you
depend upon them if you were here at
this conference I heard a speaker
earlier actually used term workflow who
here thinks about themselves as doing
things with
workflows all right all right uh cool
cool I would posit that most of you do
in one way or another in today's world
of data and Python and software you are
interacting with lots of systems is that
true true or false true true true all
right uh and you are probably having
some events happen in those systems a
lot of times right something goes wrong
something goes right you want to know
about it so uh when being able to
understand reactive events is something
that we all need uh and then if you're
working on a team you are probably not
doing this uh just by yourself when
everyone's not following the same things
all the time having a little bit of
standardization can be super helpful to
save you uh all kinds of of pain down
the road so um here what do we need
exactly to deal with this what are
solutions to being in a world where we
have lots of different systems the
screen going black uh no good okay back
um we need an API to in the middle of
those systems so that we can know what
is happening and interface with all of
them we need an API that we can act with
interact with uh in terms of automations
automatically just like boom and
something happens right when I want it
to and we need the ability for a person
to go in and say ah I actually want to
make a change here right so we want an
API that is secure easy to use and works
for people and
robots if you ask Chad gbt to make a
picture you will give back something
just as beautiful as this and I'm not
sure if you can read everything here but
it makes no sense at all
but that's sometimes how the world is
with our apis right we sitting there
interacting with lots of different
systems uh so second thing we want to do
is understand and react to events we
want to be able to observe everything
that's happening and take action
automatically when warranted and for
example maybe we want notifications
right you we're depending on some kind
of system you'd like to get an email a
slack notification pager Duty something
when something goes well or when it
doesn't maybe you want to run a
different workflow automatically in
response to something that happens uh
maybe you want to pause your workflow on
a certain infrastructure when something
happens so these are all very useful
things to be able to do in this
world I the button something should move
to the next slide move to the next
slide all right uh standardization super
useful here right if you're a part of a
team you want to bring some order to the
chaos that is out there ideally you have
some guard rails for people if you work
on a data team it's nice to have
everybody using the same thing and
making sure that everything works the
way you want so guard rails are super
useful this can help you speed up
onboarding getting all the people on
your team up to speed quickly is this
blinking for everybody or just
me okay sweet sweet yeah this is fun
right it would be fun if we didn't have
some stuff like this so we want to make
sure we have standardization so we have
uh this is a precondition for really
having some centralized observation so
what's the solution here a workflow
application framew workk who's now
excited I bet you're
excited I'm liking right so what's a
workflow system for managing these
repetitive tasks an application
something holistic interactive interface
for software that's how we're thinking
about things here and a framework
building blocks to reduce the overhead
associated with these common activities
right don't reinvent the world don't
repeat yourselves here to keep it dry so
workflow application Frameworks uh and
the whole goal of this is to save you
some time save you some money and
increase productivity so where's prefect
come in uh this is what we do uh we are
pythonic workflow application framework
for developers um we have an open source
python package and a cloud hosted
solution for teams you can check out uh
the repo that includes all of the demos
that I'm not giving because I'm out of
time uh and you can give us a little
star there along with the other 13,000
people have done so get some great
dashboard action and take care of your
workflows and make sure things are going
the way you want again the demo time is
running short so I'm going to skip that
um so one quick story here before last
30 seconds just got this message today
from someone on our team that a startup
needed a solution to power a customized
physical activity reminder for their app
that they were generating and if we want
to have workflows to run on the schedule
every time the user wants to set an
automatic schedule for when they want to
get notified uh that's a tool that that
prefi can do now with this workflow
application framew check it out F QR
code that action if you want to get
touch uh or connect on
or thank you give it up